joe and i really love sad songs we've
always bonded over music
not only are taylor swift and joe alwyn
boyfriend
girlfriend they're now also one
seriously epic
sad songwriting duo i love getting to do
this
and i i live to write songs that's what
i live for during a recent chat with
zane lowe on apple music the 31 year old
singer gave fans a little insight on how
her man helped her co-write songs on her
latest album
evermore we just really love sad songs
what can i say um
he he started that one and came up with
the uh
melodic structure of it and um i say it
was
a surprise that we started writing
together but
in a way it wasn't because we have
always bonded over music and had the
same musical tastes and he's always the
person who's showing me songs
by artists and i'm then then they
become my favorite songs credited under
a pseudonym as william bowery
joe co-wrote three songs on evermore
champagne problems
your mom's ringing in your pocket my
picture in your wallet
your heart was glass i dropped it
champagne
problems coney island
and i'm sitting on a bench in coney
island wondering where did my
baby go and the title track evermore
and i couldn't be
[Music]
a sure so peculiar
that this pain would be for
evermore you'll recall before we knew
william bowery's true identity
the lovebirds previously teamed up on
betty and exile on folklore
he's always just playing instruments and
he doesn't do it in a strategic i'm
writing a song right now thing he's
always done that
but i do i think we would have taken the
step of
hey let's see if there's an app there's
a song in here let's write a song
together
if we hadn't been in lockdown
i don't think that would have happened
and i'm so glad that it did taylor and
joe have gotten
a lot closer amid the pandemic a source
told e.t
earlier this month that joe has been a
constant for taylor during a tough year
which has not only included the
coronavirus lockdown
but also her mom andrea's health battle
meanwhile taylor told zane that she has
absolutely no idea what's next for her
something new and different for a
self-proclaimed planner and
list maker i think my new list will be
like places i want to see in the world
adventures i want to have experiences i
want to have
things i want to learn i think that'll
be what the list
looks like because you know there's
always going to be a list it's me but
taylor isn't just adjusting her to-do
list
she admits that it felt good to write
songs on folklore and evermore that
weren't about her personal life
something that's become a bit of a
swifty trademark over the years
there was a point where i that i got to
as a writer
who only wrote very diuristic songs that
i felt it was unsustainable from
from my future moving forward it felt
like
too hot of a microscope on my bad days i
would feel like i was
loading a cannon of click bait when
that's not what i want for my life
i don't have to have it feel like
when i put out an album i'm just like
giving
tabloids ammunition and stuff and taylor
says the fact that people like her new
music is a big relief
what i felt after we put out folklore
was like
oh wow people people are into this too
this thing that feels i can do this for
my life
and feels really good for my creativity
there's a way out too oh my god
um i saw i saw elaine i saw elaine for
my future that i i it was a real
breakthrough moment of excitement and
[Music]
happiness